oui pour être précis c'est parce que sa
mère avait été battu pendant sa
grossesse que les magistrats ont estimé
qu'il y avait un lien direct avec ces
troubles psychiques
toutes les personnes nées d'un viol ne
sont donc pas forcément fondé à être
indemnisée d'après ce jugement cela dit
même si les juges s'en défende
explicitement c'est bien une nouvelle
fois le regard porté sur la guerre
d'algérie qui évolue après l affaire de
la torture réactions et commentaires
recueillis par claude samper et michel
levasseur les viols commis pendant la
guerre d'algérie ont toujours constitué
un tableau quasi impossible à lever 40
ans plus tard la parole commence à se
libérer
henri pouillot appelé à alger en 1961
est l'un des rares militaires à avoir
témoigné sur le sujet pendant dix mois
il a assisté à plus d'une centaine de
viols à la villa susini 1 c'est
l'absence de tortue on avait des viols
qui est un peu de jazz nature différente
si j'ose dire en partie des viols
étaient une pratique de torture pure et
simple et une autre partie d'autres
viols étaient plus des viols à caractère
plus collectif et pour satisfaire les
soldats qui étaient sur place le général
aussaresses a reconnu récemment avoir
torturé en algérie lundi prochain il
passe au tribunal pour apologie de crime
de guerre la torture il approuve les
viols
non pour lui la décision de justice
d'aujourd'hui est parfaitement justifiée
pas géré par oui je considère qui peut
être considéré comme une victime de
guerre
du coup mieux pendant la guerre
d'algérie comme un endroit de son offre
en fait non à ma connaissance y en a eu
très peu dans la recherche et du
renseignement
les fédérations d'anciens combattants
elle ne voit pas forcément d'un bon oeil
la décision d'aujourd'hui selon elle
rares ont été les soldats français qui
ont commis des viols je pense d'abord
que ces cas doivent est rarissime
d'autre part il ne faudrait pas perdre
de vue que des viols il y en a eu ou des
tortures il y en a eu dans les deux
camps des deux côtés la décision
d'aujourd'hui permettra peut-être
d'ouvrir d'autres dossiers
mais visiblement le chemin est encore
long pour lever tous les tableaux